then I'll count down I'll just go 3 2 1
[Music]
hey great gun here today we're gonna
talk about digital illustration and
specifically my process for it I'm gonna
break it down into five easy steps sound
good okay now before you do anything
drink some coffee it's time to use your
brain step 1
prompts the first thing we need to do is
come up with some prompts to work from
these are words or phrases that will
help guide what we make so in this case
I'd like to make a new thumbnail image
for the program some words that come to
mind are community helping hand
sharing growth uplifting and strengthen
numbers we use some of these ideas as
fuel for the next step step 2 thumbnails
here's what I do make a little box
look at my prompts and start drawing
ideas that pop into my head keeping them
super loose at this point I don't really
care how they look I just want to see
how some of these ideas translate into a
visual form we're just trying to figure
it out so if you get stuck move on don't
sweat it
and go for quantity pro tip time
yourself this will put a fire under your
butt force you to work faster now it's
tough at first but over time you get
better at getting faster done is better
than perfect right man step 3
clean up by now you have a treasure
trove of sketches or if you're like me
five bad example I know but hey I found
one that works not this or this and I
didn't even finish this one here we go I
picked this one because the idea is
simple and it should read super clearly
at a small size now this will be the
foundation for our illustration the
bones the structure you can get it right
ok good good
[Music]
step four
color color is my favorite part of any
project it's kind of like the moment of
truth where you test the visual quality
of your idea our primary goal here is to
block out color for each shape in the
drawing now while I'm doing this I'm
thinking about where I want a place
visual focus and make sure those shapes
are the brightest or they have the most
contrast
[Music]
[Music]
Step five
detail so we have our color blocked in
and you'll see that I move some things
around here now we're going to place
some type in here later and I want to
make sure there's ample room for it
overall I like where we're at but it's
kind of boring so let's make it unborn
now we can do that by adding some light
and shadow keep in mind this is intended
to be a thumbnail so it's got a read
when it's very small
[Music]
better better much better now let's see
how it looks with the type I like it and
there you have it my five steps to
digital illustration now let's do the
recap step one come up with props words
step two use your prompts and get
sketching step three
pick your best sketch and clean it up
real nice step four
get yourself a pellet and block out
those colors step 5 add some detail
lines shadow lighting the six is very
important it's it's there's a lot more
that goes into making the digital
illustration than what I just talked
about conceptually and like technically
- but to go over all that we need to
make like a course or something and
that's actually something I'd like to do
but I don't know if that's something
you're interested in so let's do this if
you'd like for me to make a proper
digital illustration course maybe using
a program like Photoshop or illustrator
leave a comment let me know let's talk
about it and let's get this started I
would love to do that also if you
enjoyed this video and what we covered
in it well you know why not give it a
like maybe even subscribe to come on
you're already here it's like the
easiest thing you can do anyways it's
cool I'll good toy free my problem
[Music]
común cut back to the puppies come on
subscribe for the puppies
[Applause]
[Music]